il faut quand même rappeler que la
méthode de confinement vient de
l'élevage
c'est une méthode de médecine
vétérinaire et autant dans les cheptels
c'est une méthode qui marche
là je pense je répète ce que j'ai dit on
a été un peu à la limite de l'efficacité
du confinement ça ne règle rien le
confinement
on supprime la circulation des gens il
sert des conséquences dramatiques
et puis quand on arrête et bien tout a
tendance à repartir voilà ce qui s'est
passé en juin juillet et août
le virus a largement circulé on s'est
dit c'est terminé et on l'a vu donc
cette deuxième vague qui nous a surpris
par sa force
non il faut vraiment trouver des
alternatives au confinement qui à mon
avis a plus d'inconvénients que
davantage je les dis aujourd'hui on voit
des gens portaient le masque dans la rue
partout mais quelle est l'efficacité de
ce masque il y a des gens qui ont des
masques chirurgicaux qui sont des
masques unidirectionnelle qui sont
chiffonné qu'il réutilise à longueur de
journée ils sont portés sous le nez
parfois sous le menton et on ne se pose
pas la question de l'efficacité des
masques actuellement notre politique
c'est surtout les tests rt pcr et qui
sont faits avec je pense ou
insuffisamment de cohérence à n'est pas
je ne savais pas bien planifié les les
gens qui ont un test sont pour certains
ceux qui vont aller voyager pour
d'autres ce qui ont eu un contact pour
d'autres simplement ceux qui sont
anxieux qui veulent se tester donc les
tests dont on nous assène
quotidiennement les résultats la
positivité
ces tests ne sont pas une données
épidémiologiques satisfaisant
[Musique]